der rapper trepmann über nazis die nie
weg waren
das verrät euch auch wer heute unser
gast ist und da sitzt das schon das ist
nämlich genau eben jener trepmann schön
dass du dabei bist herzlich willkommen
ja hallo schön genommen am samstag ist
es soweit dann 30 jahre mauerfall welche
gefühle löst das bei dir aus ja die zeit
ist schnell vergangen so und ja es
kommen natürlich erinnerungen hoch
ich erinnere mich an die zeit als die
ddr quasi verschwunden ist und ich
begonnen habe unter anderem zu reißen
das heißt eben halt in die alten
bundesländer
und dann darüber hinaus auch in die welt
und viele schöne erinnerungen auf jeden
fall ja du kommst ursprünglich aus dem
osten und das thema ost west das
verarbeitet du auch ganz oft in deiner
musik und wie sich das dann genau anhört
das hören wir uns jetzt nochmal
gemeinsam an
[Musik]
tritt man singt über seine kindheit und
jugend in chemnitz als es noch kein marx
stadt hieß und in der ddr lag als die
mauer fiel war drettmann 16 dem
plattenbau der tristesse entfliehen
damals sein ziel die alten perspektiven
waren irgendwie dahin so und man konnte
reisen das habe ich getan
ich bin viel gereist und man keine
ausbildung keine ausbildung statt dessen
macht der musik und irgendwann karriere
gerade das dritte album auch über
rassismus antisemitismus
abgeschoben obwohl der probiert april
ermordete den letzten tag stolperstein
stolperstein
heute lebt tritt man in leipzig zurück
in seiner heimatstadt chemnitz sinkt da
2018 gegen rechts wieder der song über
seine jugend und über nazis die damals
schon da waren
[Musik]
das geschäft mit der hoffnung
hinter jeder tür lauern abbruch
wo ich herkomme
tritt man wir haben es gerade gehört
zuletzt auch über rassismus und deine
erfahrungen damit warum ist dieses thema
für dich wichtig ja weil warum ist
dieses thema für mich wichtig so ich
mache musik ich mag es wenn menschen
zusammenkommen um eine gute zeit
miteinander haben und hass auf grund von
verschiedener hautfarbe oder religion
ist mir halt so wieder und ist einfach
überflüssig so finde ich ja über das
thema extremismus bzw
rechtsextremismus kommen wir gleich noch
zu sprechen vielleicht gerade noch mal
zu dem ost west thema du bist ja als
musiker viel unterwegs kommt viel rum in
deutschland insgesamt magst du danach
wie vor einen großen unterschied was ost
und west angeht in der mentalität der
leute was die leute auch beschäftigt
also ich muss sagen ich bewege mich in
kreisen oder auf veranstaltungen partys
konzerten ähnlichem und das halt schon
seit dem mauerfall quasi ging das schon
los deswegen hat sich die einheit für
mich auch wahrscheinlich schon viel viel
schneller verzogen als für so manch
anderen der eben halt nicht herumgereist
ist so ich nehme es nicht wirklich war
muss ich sagen es gibt natürlich
regionen von denen ich weiß so dass die
leute eben halt nicht rauskommen und da
sind natürlich auch verschiedenheiten zu
bemerken aber du hast diese
verschiedenheiten schon innerhalb der
alten bundesländer weiß ich nicht der
pott ist verschieden zu was weiß ich zum
beispiel der nordsee kuss oder so aber
ansonsten ich nehme es nicht wirklich
war
du bist im osten aufgewachsen erst in
chemnitz bis dabei jetzt seit einiger
zeit in leipzig gab es bei dir jemals
den wunsch in den besten überzusiedeln
also ich finde ein paar städte attraktiv
aber das hat nichts damit zu tun dass es
quasi westdeutschland ist insofern nicht
wirklich so
ich habe eine zeitlang in berlin gewohnt
und ist ja auch also da ist ja west
zeigt quasi gehört dazu mehr oder minder
aber nein nicht wirklich
auf youtube schreibt uns florian h was
wäre aus stefan richter
so ist ein bürgerlicher name geworden
wenn die mauer nicht gefallen wäre für
deine idee ich kann nur vermuten aber ja
damals so der weg war irgendwie
vorgezeichnet so letztendlich halt
schulzeit abitur wenn du studieren
wolltest musstest du drei jahre sich
verpflichten als mann und zur armee
gehen dann studium vielleicht so mein
vater und meine mutter haben sich in
porzellan der kennengelernt sie war
porzellanmalerin er firma das fand ich
auch so
ich meine ich war wie alt 14 15 als ich
mich schon entscheiden musste welchen
beruf ich denn erlernen wollte das fand
ich attraktiv und ja vielleicht wäre ich
in eine richtung gegangen
wir haben es gerade schon gehört du
setzt dich in deinen texten viel auch
mit politik auseinander mit
rechtsextremismus du hast zwei systeme
erlebt wie hast du da rechte gewalt
beobachten können wir also zu ddr zeiten
gab es ja quasi offiziell kein rassismus
geschweige denn irgendeine art von neo
faschismus neonazis oder ähnlichem
das wurde quasi wenn es denn auftrat und
es trat auf es gab ja auch weiß ich
nicht glaube schon 87 zwischenfälle die
halt bekannt wurden wie zum beispiel der
überfall von neonazis auf die
zionskirche in berlin
was sich da nicht mehr verbergen diese
aber es gab so einen latenten rassismus
irgendwie der halt nie öffentlich
gemacht wurde und sich halt so hinter
den türen abgespielt hat das hat man
schon als kind fast mitbekommen kann ich
mich erinnern an schimpfworte und
ähnlichem auch gab es damals schon viel
neid auf gastarbeiter aus ländern wie
libyen beispielsweise oder
afrikanische studenten oder leute die
eben hat studiert hatten und valuta
hatten das heißt demag sich gut kleiden
konnten an bestimmten orten in der stadt
zeit verbracht haben in der milchbar
beispielsweise und da gab es damals
schon des öfteren übergriffe und das
auch wirklich in der gesamten ddr auf
ebenen fremde sozusagen michael doktor
schreibt uns beziehungsweise fragt hat
treibt man schon mal selbst gewalt
erfahren und das leider nicht nur einmal
wie gesagt also in diesen
nachwendejahren war das quasi ja wann
immer du aus gegangen bist am wochenende
oder eben in der woche was weiß ich in
den jugendclub abends der letzte
anschluss beispielsweise dort wo alle
busse dann in die verschiedenen
richtungen und stadtviertel faden so da
lief man jedesmal gefahr
ja sie schlagen zu müssen oder aufs maul
zu bekommen ganz einfach weil man ja
nicht rechts war eben halt anders außer
was weiß ich eine baseball jacke anhatte
und ein basecap oder irgend sowas
das ging ganz schnell gab es eigentlich
jemals auch nur eine situation eine
phase in deinem leben wo du empfänglich
gewesen wärst selbst für rechte parolen
vielleicht auch einfach um dem druck der
gefahr auch irgendwie zu entgehen also
die ich selber anzuschließen
nein nie so weit ich weiß nicht ich habe
mich schon als kind angefangen so für
andere kulturen zu interessieren war bin
immer noch große stevie wonder oder rsa
fränkin fan und interessiere nicht dafür
das heißt mir war auch schon zu
ddr-zeiten mir war das alles zugleich
und zu blass und zu grau so ich habe
mich quasi über einfluss und menschen
die zu uns kommen immer gefolgt
wir sprechen gleich weiter treibt man
erfahrungen mit rechtsextremisten das
treibt natürlich auch andere um künstler
aber auch journalisten zum beispiel
teilen unter dem hashtag
baseballschläger jahre ihre erfahrungen
mit rechtsextremismus inzwischen sind es
weit über 100 die da mitmachen in ost
und west und um was es da genau
erzählt uns jetzt nochmal nina
niebergall ich bin mit einem messer in
der nacht bedroht worden wie es ist mir
an den körper gehalten worden
ich bin tagsüber durch die belebte
innenstadt von 14 nazis beckenrand
irgendwie mit jemand anderem eine
richtig harte verfolgungsjagd ich habe
einen klub gesessen in einem
unterirdischen club und wir haben uns
verschanzt vor denen die draußen standen
in mehreren dutzenden bis die polizei
kam was gedauert hat geschichten wie die
von journalist christian bange gibt es
viele
er startet den hashtag baseball-schläger
jahre und viele fangen an zu erzählen
von rechtsextremer gewalt in den
neunzigern august 1990 konzert von the
cure im zentralstadion leipzig das damit
begann und endete das skins und faschos
und durch straßen und büsche jagten
straßenbahn voll nazis haben ein
ausländer drangsaliert alle haben
konzentriert und beschäftigt gewirkt und
weggesehen
es ist die zeit als rechtsextremer einer
asylbewerberunterkunft in rostock
lichtenhagen angreifen im nordrhein
westfälischen solingen fünf menschen
ermorden als rassistische gewalt zunimmt
in ost und in west deutschland
1992 gab es laut einmal de antonio
stiftung 27 opfer rechtsextremer gewalt
der höhepunkt ganz aufgehört aber hat es
nie wie 2009/10 der mord an walter lübke
und der anschlag auf eine synagoge in
halle zeigen
er setzt sich gegen rechtsextremismus 1
hendrik bolz ist rapper er schreibt
einen zeitungsartikel der hundertfach
unter dem hashtag baseball-schläger
jahre geteilt wird und in dem es um
seine kindheit in stralsund geht
rechte gruppen waren halt überall
vorhanden haben die spielplätze besetzt
haben vor der haustür um gelungen hat
waren ganz normal es gab was weiß ich
wie viele verflechtungen dass das so
größte große größere geschwister von von
freunden irgendwie rechts waren nach der
wende habe es an stabilen staatlichen
strukturen gefehlt und das wirkt bis
heute nach
dazu gehört eben auch ehrlichkeit in
ganz deutschland darüber dass in dieser
zeit was entstehen konnte was was
menschen traumatisiert und verletzt hat
und das bis heute tut nämlich offen
gewaltbereiten rechtsextremismus der
sich jetzt verfestigt hat der jetzt
strukturen hat die so leicht gar nicht
mehr zu durchbrechen
christian bangel hofft dass den hashtag
baseball-schläger jahre zumindest eine
diskussion anstößt
darüber wie es so weit kommen konnte und
was jetzt zu tun ist ja was jetzt zu tun
ist wahrscheinlich keiner ganz leicht zu
beantwortende frage hattest du eine idee
was jetzt zu tun wäre
tja also also ich nicht von meiner
heimat sprach vom dem bundesland in dem
ich aufgewachsen bin eben von sachsen
dann kann ich auf jeden fall über die
drei dekaden die die cdu da zum beispiel
reagiert sagen dass rechtsextremismus
halt immer geleugnet wurde
und ja in der zeit eben wie im beitrag
schon gesagt konnten eben halt auch
durch die mithilfe von leuten aus den
alten bundesländern also es ging
wirklich mit dem mauerfall schon los
eben netzwerke entstehen strukturen
entstehen ja unterbieten kopf hieß es ja
sachsen hat kein problem mit
rechtsextremismus seit monaten sogar
dagegen
ich weiß es gar nicht mehr genau auf
jeden fall stand der feind immer auf der
anderen seite und ist es selbst heute
immer noch so dass wann immer es um
rechtsextremismus und gewalt geht immer
auch gleich wieder eben links erwähnt
wird und ich war glaube erst diese woche
dass die cdu berlin ankam mit einem
aktionsplan gegen gewalt von links
irgendwie in der zeit wo wir gerade wo
halle wirklich ein paar wochen her ist
wir immer noch die nsu geschichte nicht
aufgeklärt haben so wirklich und ich
weiß nicht also die zeichen der zeit
deuten auf jeden fall in der andere
richtung irgendwie und dann höre ich
jetzt aber bei dir schon raus das diner
beobachtung nach sich die rechte szene
nach der wiedervereinigung auch noch mal
verändert hat auch im osten ja vorher
wie gesagt gab es keine strukturen so
soweit ich das beurteilen kann also ich
muß war 16
zu dem zeitpunkt sondern es war eher so
ein latenter rassismus halt und ab und
zu irgendwelchen übergriffe aber danach
fing es eben halt an
dass sich diese leute halt organisiert
haben und es gab halt verschiedene
vereinigungen werden sich nichts zum
beispiel in karl marx stadt damals gab
es die es ist ein ortsteil von
karl-marx-stadt die brennstoffe
volksunion oder ähnlich ist und ja da
hat man sich organisiert getroffen und
halt auch gezielt dann angefangen was
weiß ich jugendhäuser alternative zu
überfallen all das seine geburtsstadt
ist chemnitz was löst das bei dir aus
wänden jetzt für viele menschen chemnitz
immer so in einem atemzug genannt wird
bzw die assoziation da ist mit rechten
aufmärschen wie empfindest du das ja ich
meine chemnitz ist auch nur eine stadt
von vielen vorher baslers werder oder
rostock lichtenhagen
es ist einfach man kann es nicht von
nein so es ist halt passiert so und das
was da passiert ist vor einem jahr
das hätte auch schon ja vorher passieren
können oder ist in kleineren also hat
sich im kleinen auch schon des öfteren
abgespielt und das eben halt schon seit
ich weiß ich nicht youngster bin
jugendlicher bin irgendwie es ist nie
verschwunden es war immer thema so
deswegen schreckt es mich jetzt nicht
irgendwie auch sondern es ist gut dass
es gezeigt wird bei den letzten
landtagswahlen also in thüringen zum
beispiel war auffällig dass die afd eben
nicht nur von älteren da auch aber vor
allem auch von jüngeren leuten unter 45
stark gewählt worden ist über 30 prozent
wie kannst du das erklären welchen nerv
trifft die da die hardware also erst mal
kann man wohl sagen dass eben das ist ja
schon die zweite generation also all die
leute die eben seit der wende in diese
richtung gedriftet sinn haben inzwischen
also auch kinder gezeugt so insofern
überträgt sich das ja auch so und
man kann auch sagen in diesen regionen
wo halt eine große abwanderung passiert
ist ja da kommt auch nichts neues da
kommt kein input warum sollte sich das
dort ändern die leute sehen sich nach
wie vor als benachteiligt oder als was
weiß ich deutsche zweiter klasse oder
was auch immer man denkt nicht an sie
und man spielt gegen sie bezeichnen
unsere demmer demokratie und die
regierenden parteien als regime ja keine
ahnung so wird sich nichts ändern
irgendwie und ja das gefühl es ist die
die stärke der afd
oder es ist vielleicht auch die schwäche
der anderen parteien die jetzt die afg
im moment so erfolgreich sein lässt
na ja die frage ist schon eine gute
aussage das kommt natürlich auch dazu
dass es ein programm in irgendeiner art
und weise fehlt oder eben es halt immer
relativiert wurde so nur dass eben halt
nicht nur in sachsen allein so wie
gesagt thüringen und das passiert ja
überall momentan dieser rechtsruck und
ja empfinde ich schon so dass es da
irgendwie fehlt also die politik mehr
tun müssen ist einfach du tust
jedenfalls das was in seiner macht steht
um machst musik was würdest du dir
wünschen fragt mara s was würdest du dir
wünschen dass deine musik bei menschen
im bezug auf rassismus auslöst ja ich
gehe jetzt nicht davon aus dass diese
songs wirklich also maximal können sie
an regen zum nachdenken ist auch nicht
so dass ich das gern es wirklich wird
auch gern politische songs machen
aber wie gesagt ich bin halt oder ich
kann mir halt gehör verschaffen eben mit
der musik und deswegen muss das halt
auch sein irgendwie und ja im besten
fall regen sie an zum nachdenken
viele löschen jaja entschuldigungen oder
leute bekräftigen ist halt ich meine
nach einem song wie die stolpersteine
und das bestärkt mich halt auch kommt
halt so viel feedback auch leute haben
hunderte von videos geschickt wie sie
stolpersteinen putzen und das hatten wir
hatten auch nicht dazu aufgerufen oder
so ich um meine gang sondern das kamen
ganz von selbst und das ist zum beispiel
ein schönes ereignis denn sowas passiert
freue ich mich dass macht herr p großes
thema ist ja auch immer wieder die
abwanderung aus dem osten in den westen
viele leute sind rüber gegangen
was ist denn vielleicht aus deiner sicht
cooler am osten als am besten also warum
holz ist dann vielleicht doch auch im
osten wurzeln zu schlagen
beziehungsweise vielleicht sogar eine
andere richtung rüber zu gehen
ja das weiß ich nicht ist von region zu
region unterschiedlich natürlich ich mag
leipzig ganz sehr ist eine schöne stadt
und leipzig war auch wo der werdende
halt grau düster sehr viel
altbausubstanz die zuviel irgendwie und
inzwischen hat sich leipzig zu einer
sehr schönen stadt gemausert mit vielen
parks und ist natürlich auch so einem
mentalitäts bedingt das ding so ist es
meine heimat ich komme gut klar
ich mag auch die fremde ist ist auch
nicht so dass ich jetzt also ich lege
mich da auch nicht fest irgendwie fühle
mich auch irgendwie überall zuhause halt
dadurch dass dass wir das privileg daran
hatten auch zu reißen
irgendwie habe ich das getan und er weiß
nicht so ich kann mir auch vorstellen
woanders zu leben so ich kann jetzt
nicht sagen zieht nach leipzig weil dies
das muss jeder selbst herausfinden
anschauen sollte man sich auf jeden fall
gibt viele schöne regionen im osten hey
ya das gefühl sich überall zu hause zu
fühlen ist ja auch nicht unbedingt etwas
schlechtes
wir schließen den kreis sozusagen noch
mal zum anfang der sendung also
übermorgen 30 jahre
mauerfall aus dem gefühl heraus ist die
wiedervereinigung gelungen oder fehlt
noch etwas ganz entscheidendes ich nehme
sie auf jeden fall positiv waren bin
froh dass es passiert ist und ich kann
das final nicht wirklich sagen so eine
dass sie gelungen ist so weil es hätte
natürlich auch anders passieren können
oder es hätte total schief gehen können
weiß ich nicht irgendwie sie ist auf
jeden fall vollzogen worden und wird
wohl in den nächsten jahrzehnten wird es
halt weiter zusammenwachsen ja ich
glaube ich allerletzte frage hat aber
jetzt wenig mit seiner politischen
einstellung zu tun rainer hoffmann fragt
wieso trägt er die sonnenbrille fragen
viele steht da noch nie ich habe die
sonnenbrille eine weile getragen auf der
bühne die stars und mitunter auch nicht
aber irgendwann habe ich die leute nicht
mehr erkannt wenn ich die sonnenbrille
nicht auf hatte das hat sich wie zu so
einem schritt mag entwickelt und
deswegen trage ich sie und wie sie es
zum beispiel auch sehen dass so die
letzte das letzte bisschen privatsphäre
dass man quasi noch hat es fühlt sich
einfach gut an
die sonnenbrille zu tragen wenn wir uns
persönlich sehen dann nehme ich ja auch
gerne ab und schaue mein gegenüber die
augen kann ich gut nachvollziehen also
die privatsphäre sei den vielen dank
trotzdem für die sehr offenen worte
waren sehr interessantes gespräch
vielen dank tritt man und auch euch
natürlich vielen dank für eure
aufmerksamkeit der nächste stream dann
wieder nächste woche am dienstag das was
von uns zu sagen schau und bis dann
und wenn euch dieser live-stream
gefallen hat dann interessieren
vielleicht auch diese themen zum einen
warum junge ostdeutsche so oft rechts
wählen oder der hier franziska schreiber
ist afd aussteigerin sie spricht über
ungleichheit in ost und west oder ihr
abonniert einfach unseren kanal dann
verpasst er in zukunft kein live stream
er